so
i guess to start out with a
supplement to
to uh tuesday's class one thing that i
that i uh didn't
carry out uh in in our proof we tried to
prove that dijkstra's first construction
was was valid and we showed that there
weren't any infinite
sequences
of bad configurations
but
we didn't show one of the other
properties that's uh
that needs to be
that that needs to be emphasized and i
haven't mentioned it for a long time so
i hope people have forgotten it and that
is that in every configuration at least
one processor has to be able to move
it's it's fairly easy if you if you give
up that restriction it's fairly easy to
find
to find constructions that uh where
everybo where uh where you don't have
infinite cycles of bad moves because
hardly anybody can move anyway you see
them so um
so you've got to always be able to move
and then and then once you once you open
the once you open the door then
then everything keeps going
and sometimes you can go on moving
infinitely often so there's this
trade-off between trying to hold back
and and not define a move
um and uh and being forced to
to define enough moves that there's
always a way to do it
now in the uh in that in dijkstra's
particular example um
it was it was obvious that somebody
could always move and that's why i
didn't think of mentioning it on tuesday
that but we but it should have been
mentioned that remember the example was
you copy everybody except the first
everybody said the left most copies the
the neighbor on the left and the left
most can move only if the uh
its two neighbors are equal
and uh and so uh
the other if none of the others can move
then they must all be equal and
therefore
the first guy can move so that's the
proof in that case but it has to be
it has to be um
verified otherwise
okay now the other thing was it was uh
in the
there was some discussion after class as
to why
um certain constructions uh that seemed
to work didn't work and uh
and i wanted to uh
to go through in a little slower detail
the proof that with five processors and
two states each uh
there's no way to to to achieve it so
um with five processors
um we observed that that when when they
all had two states
um
that the sequence of moves had to always
go
uh in the same direction if if in in a
good cycle so so first of all we know
there's a good cycle
starting in the good cycle then
if for example processor zero moved
first and then processor one then we
could conclude
that or sorry whenever if processor i is
followed by processor i plus one in the
good cycle then we proved that the next
one had to be processor i plus two
and uh so it had to be marching around
and around in one in that same direction
all uh in the entire cycle
now we didn't
write down the f the the final part of
the proof that said that that therefore
when n is five or more that there's a
bad uh there's an infinite sequence of
bad configurations and let's let's do
that now
start out
with let's say five and we suppose we're
in
and and we can give ourselves uh um i
suppose x0 x1 x2 x3 x4
is a
good
is a good uh
uh an element of a good cycle
that's in which x zero in which uh uh
well let's let's write down the good
cycle uh for a reference
uh this will take a little while but it
starts out like like this
um
and x zero x one but
oops and then
they're all complemented
and then the first one is uncomplimented
and so on
so that
so in general we'll be able to get a
pattern like this
where
everything but the last is complement
and then this comes back to the
beginning
so these are all known to be
part of the states
i know as we know that if x 0
has x 1 on its right and x 4 on its left
then it can move
to x there then then it moves to x 0 bar
we also know that if x1 has x0 on its
left and x2 on its right then it does
not move
okay now the the bad cycle comes from
something like this which i saw i think
dimitri put it on the board after class
on tuesday
and
you start out with something like this
x0x1 bar x2 bar
x3 bar x4
yeah right right you had ones and zeros
instead of zeros and ones yeah
now let's take a look at who can move
and and and what we know about this okay
so x0x1
uh excel has x1 as x1 bar on the right
and x4
um alone on the left and
claim that that it can't move
wait a minute you know
do we know anything about that
we don't know for sure
i don't think that's the state has
occurred before x1 but in this this
situation has occurred and we know that
that this one i'm putting the y here
saying yes it can move
uh this one can't move
this one
um occurs occurs in here x2
x2 bar x3
we don't know this one
um
but i think this in this case it does
not it's known that that one can't move
and we have some partial information
here
now i don't have to write down in in
fact if if these were all question marks
except for the y
anyway
i know for sure that in the next state i
can go to
x0 x1 x2 bar x3 bar x4
and
and uh
the
one of the keys in this in this
construction is is to realize that
you don't have to take all of your moves
in fact if everybody moves when they
have to then again it's easy to make
these constructions but unfortunately
these pokey machines that some of them
will just pass if they have a chance and
so uh so this this state can certainly
be followed by this state and and maybe
by others
and so now
uh we try to we can do the same uh the
same thing and uh
this guy can move
this guy
uh cannot this guy can move
anybody who's sort of on a leading edge
here we've got to be a little careful at
the boundaries
this guy
cannot move
and i don't know about this one
but anyway there's a way to go
that would take
say
x2 is next
and do that move
for example
and what i want to do is make a few more
moves and get back to the starting point
or or something
sufficient actually i'm going to get to
the complement of the starting point so
that's my destination
is to get to x0 bar
x1 x2
x3 x4 bar
which is
for which the same analysis will apply
because if you complement everything you
get the same information as before
and so uh that's the i want to get to
that
and then i'll be in then i'll be in a
loop after going through one more
one more time
okay so what do we got on this case um
we're trying to complement x4
x3 and x0
and
um so we're ready to complement x0 now
this guy can move
this one can't um
i don't know about these
uh but let's do it let's do x x0
so now
um
this is
this is like those puzzles of change
blood into tears or something you know
change sober to drunk changing one one
letter at a time
um
okay um
so in this case it's interesting that
that we i think we know them all this
one can't move
uh this one can
this one
can't
this one can
this one i think
can't if i haven't done this wrong but
anyway
this one
okay x4
i was gonna move x3 but uh
it's uh in fact you're right um
uh this one is uh
this one is uh yes and this one is
questionable yeah because i never have a
situation like that you know
i never have a
compliment
in the middle of two n complements in in
the other
yeah right
so so i want to move x4
uh yeah to x4 bar
and then um
okay so now just enough room here
this is the one where it was no yes no
yes no
i think
but
we do have
we do have the ability to move x3
and so
until the the one who moved
was um
and put a circle around
this one i'll move
and um
this one
and then this one
this one this one
some kind of a goose stepping
pattern of moves there
which uh which we know without filling
in any of the question marks we know
that this will that these will be
possible moves
and that's the way the contradiction is
reached of uh that that the uh the whole
thing can't possibly work no matter how
we fill in the question mark
okay any comments on this
you can use a slight variant of that
argument to show that
you can in any larger situation you
can't have four two-state processors in
a row okay um
that's the next thing to talk about is
is uh how many two-state this is the
influence of two state processors
and um
and uh
that and i stand uh
it looks that it it's uh when i when i
posed the problem i had this uh this
this feeling that with two-state
processors i might be able to
uh
pump information through
from from both left and right
through to through a narrow channel of
only two states
because the two-state processor would be
able to read the states of both its
neighbors and therefore
govern actions however
um that doesn't work and uh so it it
looks as though in fact
um
there's a there's a general
there's a general result
uh that that is if you have at least
three
two-state processors in the system
then
uh
every good cycle has to be
has to be unidirectional
that there's no
at least that that no it forces us away
from
studying bi-directional
systems because if we have if we have
any
if we have any uh hope of
trying to
to do uh
to do the thing with uh with less than
asymptotically three to the n processors
times some constant
we would have to certainly have more
than
about a finite number of
of processors with two states in them
and uh this uh and this would mean that
we would have
three or more
uh processes with two states
and uh that's and then there's no way to
there's no no way to have a construction
that's gonna that's gonna have a good
cycle like where the moves go sometimes
the left and sometimes to the right
so that's the uh
that's the way
uh
it looks it looks there and i you know
and i see that other people were making
similar uh
uh
we're seeing it in similar ways
when i when i came to class today
um and uh
so let's take a close look at this at
this situation because uh this is the
way that you know there's no
it's turned out that that the problem is
forcing us into one into us a close
study of one-way
mechanisms even though these two-way
ones work so nicely with three-state
processors
it's uh all the uh
all the mechanism on that it's gonna be
isn't is to fail when we when we try to
get down to more two-state ones
um
so of course i want help on this but i
but i think i have a way of setting it
up that that's fairly
uh
that's that's fairly powerful if we if
we if we careful
if we please do it carefully and so i
i'm going to start off with
the assumption that there are
three
two-state processors at least
and then i don't care how many states
are in the other processors
uh you know a million doesn't matter
and i'm going to
assume that that the first processor
has uh two states
and um let's see i hope this works
uh a and i'll and and i'll start on a
good cycle and i'll write the first
element of a good cycle as a zero alpha
zero b
zero
theta zero
c zero gamma zero
where
alpha zero is the
is the configuration of the of
processors between okay i've got three
two-state processors
and i call their states a0 b0 c0 and in
between
in something i want to suppress by
having a compact notation
is any number of states of processors
that are more that that may have more
than two states are or may not
and i'll call those configurations
alphas alpha zero beta0 and gamma zero
and uh we'll assume that i chose this
starting part so that it will let the
first move is um to a zero bar
um
alpha zero
b
zero beta0 so on now
um
so without loss of generality we can
certainly set up the problem in this way
anyway and and the we get information
about any good cycle first we know there
is a good cycle so we so we can write it
down abstractly
and we and we and we can also
say
from this
that you know we know that a0 can move
when it's
followed by the first uh
the first element of alpha zero
and preceded by the last element of
gamma zero
um
in um
it's possible that alpha zero could be
an empty string
uh i guess and gamma zero could be empty
string and then we you know we'd move to
b zero c zero or something like that if
it it but if we
if we uh
don't want to worry about empty strings
in the proof at least for the beginning
we can assume that all of these are not
empty
and then
uh
you know and then work on that but uh
but at the moment let's just let's uh
we we know then that that uh that all
that that all of these
configurations here are situations where
they can't move for example if beta0
is preceded by b0 and followed by c0
none of these processors in there can
move
so we get information about somebody can
move when somebody can't a lot of it
just by looking at a good cycle okay now
um
uh now i
i'm also assuming that i chose my
notation so that the next move will be
in the alpha by the by the you know the
the next move will be to the right of
of of the first processor otherwise i
flip the whole thing
over mirror image like we've done before
so so now what's going to happen is that
some moves are going to go on to the
right
and
it's possible
that um
that a0 is going to will flip back again
and then
you know a0 might flip back from a0 bar
but back to a0 again
because it looks at the at the states
that that it now has uh you know alpha
zero is going to move to another one but
that's a processor
with
with lots of states
and our argument for two processors that
said that you couldn't go right and then
left
depended on depend on the two-state
situation
i constructed it i constructed an
example where the sequence of steps was
went like this
um
you know then it's the same same pattern
you go back one and
and and
then it cycles so i i was looking at six
processors and then i came back to
sort so i had a sequence of where the
where every
the the first processor had two states
the next one had four then two then four
then two then four
and so in the total of my as i went
through this uh
this cycle i had
i i started out with zero
say zero zero zero zero zero at the end
i ended up with zero
two zero two zero two if i named the
states
starting with zero and whenever i step i
go to the next one not mod the number of
states in that processor and so one more
time around would take me back and this
would this would be a conceivable good
cycle
because this one would look and if it
would have a one on the front on his
right it could it it could move back to
zero again
but then when zero followed by one could
move to the right so it's possible that
that um
this thing is going to flip back
back after this in in the good cycle
if we're considering the most general
case however it's even if it flips back
gamma is never going to move
because we know that gamma is stuck when
it's followed by alpha zero and it's
also stuck when it's followed by alpha
zero bar and that's the only two cases
and so
and so that's the the key to the whole
thing that no matter that that c zero
gamma zero is stuck
followed by both zero and one followed
by both possible right neighbors uh it's
stuck and so there's no way to ever
pass the baton
to the left of the of the thing to to
anybody there in the good cycle i mean
you know what i mean by patch the baton
in a good cycle
you know
the moves have to go from somebody to
its neighbor and there's only one
exactly one person can move one
processor can move at every time hi
um
i was saying before class that the
europeans have trouble
with um
uh with our
what do they call it uh
not humanization of computers but
there's another word that they use what
anthropomorphism yeah they think that's
really that's really dreadful to uh to
use anthropomorphic terminology for
computers but i i just can't do research
without it i mean it's it's restricting
such a part of the language where we
have so many uh
other verbs and
and adjectives that we can use
uh uh
that
how can you how can you actually study
something without without uh
using you know using what the language
was originally designed to talk about
so uh
you know i don't have any problems with
that i hope i hope you don't either in
fact i overheard
people talking that way and it didn't
bother me at all
okay so after a certain number of steps
then it's got to happen
i claim that we that the uh that there's
a time when beta 0 um
uh first change b zero first changes to
b zero bar
now
okay so so um at which time these
haven't changed at all
however
here we've got a1 and alpha 1 some
strings that
i'll choose to call
a1 and alpha 1. i don't know that a1 is
a 0 or a0 bar but i know that it's
either 0 1
so i just give a name to it
now
now what do you think about this
situation
once again now we know that
b0 and b0 bar no no now i have to now i
have to ask
where does the baton go next
at some point i know that every
processor in a good cycle gets it gets
exercised and so it had to get to it
couldn't just stay here and go back and
forth so it had to get
and and it couldn't go back to the left
so it had to go to the right and reach b
zero
but now
how can i continue this argument and
show that it's got to continue going to
the right
oh well yeah well it's pretty obvious i
guess mike no if it doesn't go right now
it'll never be able to get right we'll
never get to see zero because we're
blocked there's no way to go to the left
okay but but if we had only two state
if if i had started out with a with a
smaller construction only two
then it would be conceivable that beta0
was empty
and then i had a two-state processor at
the left end and the two-state processor
at the right end
and that the and that we could have a
good configuration going back and forth
in fact
uh dijkstra has actually constructed
such a thing all the processors in the
inside have four states in his in his
construction
um
and uh
but it works for any in general for any
end that you have two you have two
states
um
at either side and then uh ricocheting
uh back and forth uh and also having all
the other properties that we need to
fill filling it in so that there's
always somebody can move and always
converges and fine
time and so on but with three that we're
gonna have to go to the right otherwise
we'll never reach the third the third
processor so this argument wouldn't work
for two but with three uh it's it's it's
it's gotta work and so now uh we're in
the same situation we had before it has
to move at this point
to the right
and uh and this alpha one a1 alpha one
followed by either zero or one is known
to be uh
dead
so after a certain amount of time we get
to a point where we reach c0
and then goes to c0 bar
um
and that will exercise
the third
processor
and now
we continue in a cycle so this will be
take us to b1 beta1
and
so on
um
the same thing is going to happen where
we go a1 alpha 1 a1 bar
alpha 1.
um
c
one gamma one
c one gamma 1.
okay now add n to add m to to all
subscripts or i i guess
ok
so everywhere you see a sub 0 read a sub
i alpha sub zero is alpha sub i and
every time you read sub one call it sub
i plus one
and the same
thing is going to hold
out infinite
and then uh
since these
these strings are eventually finite it's
going to eventually be specific there's
going to be some
p so that a sub
0 is going to equal a sub p and a sub 1
is going to equal a sub p plus 1 and so
on but my notation here is not depending
on all on how many states there are in
these processors it just says that this
pattern is going to go and go on and on
uh and the good cycle has got to have
this every good cycle defines
a sequence of a's alphas b's betas and
stuff like that
um
that
that has certain properties we want to
figure out what the properties are
and the and the final
clincher which i haven't been able to
figure out how to do but uh
i haven't spent much time on it but i
think that it's it's within which it
within reach is to is to try to
construct
a uh
an example showing that uh we're we're
not we're going to be able to get an
infinite sequence of bad moves
of bad positions
um
uh based on information that we gather
from this
this is my i mean it's something i mean
i'm assuming that if i started two
places in the period
that there would be a way to
they're gonna need more than three two
for two states
right i might i don't know i mean it's
um i uh it's uh
but it anyway this kind of a pattern
would also work of course for four four
or five or six some finite number
um
and um
so i want to make sure first everybody
understands uh
that this
this was once
this was forced
with with four state processes that rule
out that
with four two state processors
the forty state processes you can you
can make one of these constructs oh that
works in the direction
it doesn't have
any psyche at that stage
that's that's an interesting point and
so you need so we couldn't possibly come
up with the construction
because you could have the other one of
these are simulated yeah yeah if these
are not if we require these alphas to be
non-empty we could
conceivably do it but otherwise we can't
um
yeah
because we have an example of the four
state of the four
processor case that
that just
happens to work
yeah
right
before i erase this i want to mention i
had this i i worked out the state table
for a situation like this where i went
you know two two states four states two
states four states so on and i and uh
everything seemed to work together very
beautifully i
i worked out you know all the moves that
were occurring in these things and
and uh
the uh
you know the force
the four
state ones i encoded as two binary
as as two two variables and there was a
there were nice equations uh
uh
saying how these would change based on
their neighbors and i could put together
two good cycles that just perfectly
matched and intermeshed with each other
and it seemed to me that
that everything was sort of being
dictated to me by higher authority that
this had to be
uh this had to be a good you know
this construction was was going to be of
some interest
because it was all fitting together uh
by magic and finally i had the whole
thing down and i could even prove that
everybody in every situation somebody
could move
and uh oh well this must this is just uh
too good to be true so i wrote a
computer program to check it out
and i found a bad cycle of length 32 uh
in in the darn thing so i could so i so
the whole thing is is wiped out
i have no construction
that
that works in six processor case not
even in the four processor cases
on that one
but
we can
we can deduce certain things about this
and this says that for example we can
say that a
sub i alpha sub i
zero and one
alpha sub i cannot move
none of the processors in in there when
alph alpha supply is preceded by a sub i
and followed by either zero one
uh uh
there's it's impossible for alpha sub
body to move
um
and um
uh why is that well
because here's a
for example here's a place where
uh
where they don't move
followed by
zero and followed by one
and so they can't move
okay
um
that's um
uh
on the other hand a a i bar
alpha
um
and and uh followed by
b sub
i
minus one
alpha i can move
and in fact
this leads after a certain number of
steps
to
i'm sorry it's bi
it's this case
because eyes are equal
these after a certain number of steps to
ai plus one alpha i plus one
bi um
uh if if a
i is preceded
by um
gamma
gamma i um
this
is a technicality but
i don't really know that this would lead
to this unless i unless i know the uh
if the if if the motion ever passes back
to the left it also depends on having
on on knowing this the
the neighbor of the left most neighbor
of uh of a so it has to be preceded by
if a i if it on the left is preceded by
the last character ci gamma
which is not empty because ci at least
is is not empty
uh then then i know that that that this
uh that it'll march through this this
configuration
um but
but if if it's not if if ai is preceded
by another thing
or if it's followed by or if alpha is
followed by um
the opposite var
then
um
it's not cl it's not sure what this will
go to it's it's possible that it's first
step you can take but then after that uh
we go
it's not uh it's not absolutely clear
that this is gonna
what this is going to do it might
it might go on and on looping
indefinitely in which case uh
the whole thing is bad and and we don't
need
uh we don't need to worry about it i
mean if that's a bad case
it might go it might die out it might be
it might if if we put bi bar here or
or the wrong symbol in front of uh where
there could be you know lots of lots of
different symbols the wrong symbol in
front of this it's possible that this
would would go into an infinite loop uh
but then um we don't worry uh it's
possible also that it would die out
completely
because because that situation never
occurred in the good cycle
and
so uh of course then we would have to
argue that uh
that somebody has to move in any
configuration so there must be some
other place that that something can go
on but it's
it's uh it's a nuisance but it's
possible that it can die out completely
and it has to be taken into account
um but but
but if if we happen to know that that
this is surrounded by the right
environment then we then we do know some
transition
about these
about the alphas that the alphas and
these will will move in that in that
fashion
now we got so that's
that's information that we've got then
we also have
one more
piece of
data
and that is uh
if i hope to help i have this right if i
have alpha i plus one
i'm assuming that they're not empty now
i guess i can
i don't need that assumption
and then i say b
i
theta i
um
v i can move
and
and then of course in this one
vi bar
it cannot
i i guess i gotta follow this oh let's
forget about the case that it's
let's assume that these alphabet and
gamma are non-empty
i think
as as
anil points out that we aren't going to
get a proof in general for just three
uh
if we allow the possibility of empty
things here
everything is consistent with uh with
still having a good situation so if we
if we we might have
a way to if we assume that these these
are non-empty
then
um
we might be able to construct uh
something that would would show that
that uh
uh
you've got to have at least
um
i mean that that's that you can't have
three two-state processes
with uh with uh non-empty things in
between them
and that would show that you couldn't
have any more than
that you couldn't have any more than six
or something two-state processes
so so in this situation b i can move in
this situation it can't move
and i made these not empty so that i
wouldn't have to worry about going going
further
in this notation
and um
the there's the end condition is
slightly different
a sub
i
alpha i
gamma
i plus 1
is that a sub i
um
i'm sorry
i
i got this is not my notes here wait
wait a minute what do they do
oh i have another
another um
line here
ace alpha
sub i
b sub i
beta sub i
b i can't move that's another that's
another um i want to i just want to
abstract all the all the information
that i can get so because we can use
that as you know that's the ammunition
that we have for proving anything yet
the uh
the uh
the limits or axioms that we have to
have to go on for constructing anything
out of this so let's get all the try to
get all the mileage i can out of the out
of the out of the data
um at a higher level and then
there's a similar case at the
at the left point but it was something
like
a i
alpha
gamma i minus
one um
no sorry gamma i
uh it says that ai can move
um
and ai bar
uh it can't then after
and finally
also in gamma i minus one
a i
alpha i
a i can't
or processor i i guess i should really
say can't move
so the the subscript of this of the of
the left neighbor
is decreased by one in the case of the
of the uh of a
oh but b and c you know there's some
there's some uh
point where where the subscripts are
are against us where we have to we have
to have to go into the next lap
around the track and and if our
subscripts say what lap we're on okay
if i had chosen the subscripts to be
you know sort of
um
a zero b minus a third c minus two
thirds and then no plus sorry this would
be one third two thirds and then
one one third one and two thirds and so
on then every
you know then everything would be uh
i would need a special rule for the for
the left case in the right case probably
but otherwise they do
so
so now uh uh
uh
as a neil said that
you've got a chart on your though this
is scribbling yeah
yeah i mean but but the scribbling i
think is is the right kind of scuba
diving i mean here here's the situation
right
you got two state projects there's that
the guy there's a guy in the middle too
he's this he's a central demon here
oh okay i was trying to use this truck
for two purposes at the same time okay
well
the the
yeah
i didn't
mean to to to
say that that was anything more than the
kind of scribbles i have in my
on my pad there but the but uh uh
the
uh
the next step in
that i can see although somebody else
might have a better idea would be to try
to construct
a pattern like this like i did here
where we've got enough feet
yeses in our information to show that we
can get into a loop
although but we have situate at least uh
you know but we have a place where we
know that there's two moves that can be
made and so we try to find
we tried to uh to to use the fact that
we have this
we have this structure
uh in order to come up with a
you know come up with it with an example
ramsay what do you think
i don't know you're not taking the nose
oh yeah
that's right somebody's
somebody it has to say without thinking
um john what do you think
around with you know it's good
we just reflect it off
okay
well anyway this this uh you know so so
uh um
although there's this construct the
other the other uh
construction that
that has only two two-state processors
and bounces back and forth it's
interesting but i don't see that it's
relevant to our problem so i don't think
we look at that one anymore so that
looks like the name of the game has to
be to uh uh to try to disprove this uh
uh if we can't disprove it we might also
come up with a construction that works
um
by seeing why this group doesn't work as
we as we said the other day
but what what other
can you describe
what uh
uh
the state of what i mean other people i
know have have come to this kind of a
conclusion that that two-state things
have to go
unidirectionally and
maybe if you hadn't uh that's okay uh
mike did
you you what was your basically the same
reasoning we went through
um
it's very much like this yeah you end
once um i was working with neil and
roger on this last night actually
uh once you get to a
two state
um
once you get to a two-state processor
you either have to reflect that point or
go across and if you go across you can't
come back
and so as soon as you've got
um
it's not two or enough
i suppose if you've got intervening
processors on both sides
sorry two two two state processors are
enough to make you interdirectional if
you've got something between them no i
don't think so no you can have a
selection of both no i have to yeah if
they're at the end
if they if they're if they're also
neighboring
no
i meant if you had something between the
one person
oh yeah oh
right if i had a
if i had a non-empty
um
if beta if beta0 was not empty
then i would then again uh we would have
had to go
march around that way that's true
because uh otherwise they wouldn't be
able to get into beta0 at all yeah
when dijkstra's construction on the uh
on this uh
he's got a two-state and then a lot of
fours and then a two
and it's interesting that the
the two ones on the end don't look at
each at at you know the one on the left
end doesn't look at the one on the right
end and vice versa
they're
um
they only look at their two numbers so
so this that's a construction
for um
uh
a non-cyclic
uh you know a straight line of
processors that don't that don't loop
loop on each other and uh and actually i
i think
we might even show that you need
something like four to the n
states
for such a case instead of three to the
n because the three to the n
type construction doesn't work and i
think uh
that
that you might that i think it's uh
possible to show that there's no
there's no way to do it with all three
state processes in
in in there anyway i don't know if you
can have some reason for some floor
but um
so he had a two-state on on the left
that never that never uh looked to the
other one and yeah and uh it was
something like this uh
i'll erase this and then but
he had each each of the states was
actually two parts
and so
your your state would be uh in fact i
can just
give you
the true uh
the true clue here the the state at the
at the left was sort of x0
and then fix the bottoms part of the
component of the state to be r where the
bottom component is either r or l for
right or left
and then the other things in the middle
um
x n minus two d sub n minus two these
these are either l or r the x's are
either zero or one and then the final
one at the right hand end
was always the bottom component was
always fixed by by an l essentially and
then the rules
for these processors in the middle here
depended on looking at the at
this you know the states on the
neighbors as to whether they were in the
l or r states
and so this d1
would always see an r there even though
that's really you know the state it's
it's unchanging so this processor has
only two states
um
and uh
the the the sequence of good states the
baton went to the right meant to the
left and to right and left
and
since these two processors at the end
each had two states
you could
you could combine them into one four
state processor
i mean this one wasn't really looking at
the
at its right neighbor at its left
neighbor and this one wasn't looking at
its right neighbor so you could combine
these two in half
and have n minus one four state ones if
you if you wanted to have four states in
every processor but
but uh anyway that's the that's uh
uh that kind of construction doesn't
work it doesn't you know it it can't go
on when you have more than two
are these uh two-state guys so
um i forget it
i'm not sure of this but
i think
if you have more than two two-state
processors in a row i mean consecutively
uh
the
this pipe sort of cannot
and you have let's say processors which
have more than two sets on one side
you're going in one direction
this pipe of two two-step processes in a
row is not capable of passing on the
information from
one end to the other
another state another
i mean essentially it cannot pass on the
entire state of of the processor to the
left it's left to the processor that's
right it's it's uh it's the the uh
it's a pipe you call it in other words
yeah we'll get filter
something in where you had only two bits
of information so that so so two in a
row would would definitely lose
uh that that it could only uh
see
these other things because things are
going so
asynchronously
and uh history
we can't count on history if we if if we
could count on a processor is always
always moving when they could
then we could devise some scheme where
you could transmit a sequence of of bits
but but in this case we don't know that
the guy has is just a sleeper if he's
doing anything i had this uh this grand
idea that that
when you've got when you go cyclically
um like this uh
uh
and um
we would try to set up
the
the
the scheme so that everybody would
always be moving to the right and our
only problem would then be two what
about multiple waves what if there's
three batons going around
uh or two batons you know going around
like this one actually is sort of what's
happening is two batons being
you know what you know they move uh in
in jerk
and so i thought okay what i'll do is
i'll have at the end i'll have a filter
that has the process that it only takes
half of the way it only gets half of the
waves through
but i wanted to take the ceiling of half
so if there were if there were k waves
in the system i wanted ceiling of k over
two waves to come through
afterwards so that one would stay which
they won but two would would drop to one
three would drop to two
four it would drop to two and so on and
then sooner or later we get down to only
one wave left
and so it seemed that going to be fairly
easy to make us it's it for lisa make a
filter that goes to k
the floor of k over 2.
namely you hold back every time you get
a chance to
the first time you get it somebody gives
you the baton you you go into a waiting
state and don't
don't send a signal to the to to to your
right neighbor
and the second time
you
you send it and then and so so the one
the filter has a few has a bunch more
states that the
uh you know we can afford to have a
filter at the at the uh
somewhere in the network and everybody
else would be would be very simple uh
always moving to the right some some
fashion that would do this
and so you know i had some hope that
we'd have
a situation where there could be any
number of twos in there
in there
maybe with threes or four sprinkled
together with them but uh
uh so that we didn't have the problem
with consecutive twos but anyway just so
that they would know that there was a
baton
and then this filter
but i couldn't get one for the ceiling
of
of k over two on the floor of k over two
and that and uh without without some
kind of a
a forcing condition
uh
so uh with my floor of k over two
this the network goes dead
um if there's only one wave and he's
waiting there to get this to get the
next one before he before he goes and
sends out the patan the second
so uh with my floor of k over two i uh
this the network goes dead
um if there's only one wave and he's
waiting there to get this to get the
next one before he before he goes and
sends out the paton the second time
um
he just you know waits and waits and
nothing happens nobody's every
everybody's waiting for for him to to
keep the last fire burning
and uh and there's no way that he can
you know send out a query saying are you
alive because
people don't have to uh
uh you know they only have two they only
have
the only one way of sending this
information to there so
so uh i i couldn't
see any way to make such a filter and uh
and so the
it looks like now the
proper thing to do is to prove that it
can't be that that that once we have a
uh
uh
a thing where everything is moving to
the right we have sufficiently many
things
that there will always be a uh be an
example
or at the very least a minimum number of
states that you have to have
yeah a minimum number of
first solution
oh yeah yeah well we have three to the
end too i mean
oh yeah
see i i see
is a one
two that's it that would be interesting
yeah to see how
how many states you need in in
if the good cycles can only pass to the
right or something like that
um
now now um there by the way there's
other uh there's there's other
interesting problems
if
if this one doesn't
you know
one of the things when you're doing
research
you don't have to stick to your original
problem
it's a little different from
most school work
that is
one of the
most important things in research is
really to ask
questions
and think of new questions and answer
those um
it's a little harder for
i mean i can't just
give an assignment saying
now for your fourth problem i want you
to ask a question and solve it
because
you get into a loop you know then the
correct answer is
answer a question ask a question and
solve it
and uh
but uh that's really what research is
often and what i had to do in this
fourth problem is i started out and
saying okay look i know that
that
after after 10 years since i should
publish this paper it'd be good to think
about it
again and there must be something that
hasn't been solved about it yet what is
it so
so first i i thought i would i would ask
could you do it with all two state
processors and then it was shot down
um so this was my next my next question
but there are other questions
um
uh that
that are um
interesting enlightening not
maybe you can think of some anybody one
one of ones that occurred to me that i
would like to to explore if i had time
this weekend
would
but i won't
have time
uh would be to find
for five processors uh the best i can do
i i i
i've got a let's you know can i do it
with
yeah we three to anything less than
three to the fifth dijkstra solution has
a two four four four two which is 256
states uh
configurations and
and uh three to the fifth is 243. so
that's bill that's the the best one but
could you do it with with with two
states and some threes
and uh
and this is a this is an interesting
constraint
problem or
backtracking thing where where you uh
where you start out and say well i
assume that my good
configuration is going to is going to
have this this many things in it so i
start to fill in the state tables and
then you then
you have
a list of let's suppose for example that
you
that you're trying to do one that has
two
two two state processors at each end and
three is in the middle
so that gives you a total of 27 times
four is
10
8
uh 108
configurations
that and uh and so you have a you have a
graph on 108 vertices um where there's
arc from one
from one vertex to another if that if
that's a
a possible transition
from that configuration to the other
and you're looking f and uh on some of
the uh
on some of the uh uh
some of the vertices you'll know the
full
the full uh story exactly which ones it
can lead to on other ones you'll have
some question marks that you don't know
but you can but uh you can
look at the ones that have no question
marks and and maybe find that there's a
cycle of bad moves
you see if you have a graph
you can
look that for the properties that the
graph is supposed to have the properties
between configurations
one of the properties is that every
every vertex
has out degree now that
at least one every vertex has at least
one successor
the number of successes of a vertex is
uh
is either 1 3 7
uh 15 or 31 in this case because
uh if you've got
k things that can move there's two to
the k minus one
successor
uh so you ca so so anyway the vert so so
the vertices that uh so every vertex has
at least one successor uh then we got
the property that um
uh
if you have exactly one successor
and if that successor has exactly one
and so on and keep on going
and you never get to somebody who has uh
who has more than one successor in this
process
then you can call such verse such a
vertex good
and uh
and uh if you
but if you can get to a situation where
there's where there's a bear that comes
back to itself then you know you're out
of luck
and so you can you can
uh you can reject you can you can look
for the the most interesting uh
uh part of your of your
specification that hasn't been filled in
and try to
and and see if there's a way to do it
that would just construct then um
a solution if there was one with a
smaller number of states
so
that
might or might not be possible
uh we know for four processors that you
can do with 16 states it just seems
strange that with five you'd have to go
all the way up to 254 43.
okay now um
so let's let's
let's tr uh our return to the
i haven't gone around the table yet
anybody else have
have partial
hints to the
to the problem
everybody looks at their papers i guess
there's nobody's anxious to talk anyways
okay everything is good you have random
scribbles yeah so let's take let's try
something like this suppose that i start
out with a zero
alpha zero
b one
um
beta 1
what c1 gamma 1 for example what what
can we you know just to try that
does that give us anything
uh what what do we know about
about that other than that it's with a
different color of chalk
what what can what can you say about
this uh
about the successor to this uh if
anything
it's probably well i think what we
really need to find is this if you look
at one of the sequence like the sequence
of bis
and
find
some part where that matches itself so
that you can shift it okay
so so uh look at the b this sequence b0
b1
b2 and and see if there isn't uh
if that
doesn't have a cycle that's smaller than
the cycle of of the alphas
and so instead of this one here you're
putting
you're you're you're putting a k on here
say maybe maybe
and maybe we maybe you could do it with
with the assumption that beta k is
non-empty no we can't just
we know that there's a four-state
solution to this with no contradictions
so
okay now um
equals
a zero
what a
a k plus one equals a zero yeah a k plus
one
equals a zero
and
uh
just we didn't measure
gamma zero equals gamma k
gamma zero equal gamma k
and uh
let's get through uh alpha zero equals
alpha k
oh
so we have enough assumptions here
then
all right
yeah then
okay well
something i mean it's not
oh what yeah uh what what um
you know we
the nice thing about this is even though
we have question marks we can sometimes
steal the code somewhere and write it
i think it's very cool off the cable
screen just
thank you but it looks like but i think
roger's point is that knowing something
about
the uh
the this finding a sub
pattern among the bees or maybe the last
letter of gamma k or something like that
okay uh
anyway go ahead mike i'm sorry i
interrupted you
um if prophet zero equals alpha k plus
one instead
then i think we get two
zero this one yeah
and we're going to get well then now
zero and then uh we're
yeah we got a cycle i mean k is not the
period though huh
okay
well now what we're going to do is we're
going to get both pk both a and b are
ready to change at the moment
wait a minute if you've got this
then we're just sitting at part of we're
in the middle of our
i mean then we're sitting at alpha then
we're
we know everything
this is something that we
write except that
we also know that ak and gamma k are
related
sorry akm plus one and gamma k really
okay so we get a short cycle here so i
want to get and see where both a and b
are gonna be we have to find a place
that we
i would
this can't be bad if it's
if it's if it's equal to one of the
elements in the good cycle
we've got to start out with something
we have to we have to have some
assumptions that make it bad
so we're going to have to have some
question marks in here because they will
be situated probably because they want a
situation that won't occur in a good
cycle
but here's an example how we were able
to do that
just by knowing what's in the good cycle
we were able to
prove that there's a bad cycle without
it without any other
consumption
but uh let's
so anyway that was too much this was too
much
but uh but what what
what if we have no assumptions what can
you what should we say
there's something we can we can say
about this when you've got these on
these properties
first of all it says that ai
alpha i can't move so we got we got all
knows
the thing we were looking at last night
and the first thought all jumped up and
said yeah well this problem solved now
and
the idea was to have four
four two state processors and in in a
ring
and you have intervening processors
between all of them
and
like this oh you mean you have the
intervening one yeah you just got a ring
okay
that has just you know
a square if you want whatever yeah okay
and the idea is that if
you know each
and so so in the good configuration you
just got one signal that's wandering
around yep the ring
and the idea is that any given side of
the square
will
not be able to distinguish it
i mean it's a signal that's supposed to
be there from one that isn't so i mean
you see you just look at the top side of
the square and when the the state on the
left changes there's a picture for the
baton right
when the state on the left changes it
goes through its routine and eventually
ends up changing the one on the right
and goes back to a dormant state
and
it's i mean if if the next baton comes
too soon it's not going to know that
yeah
and the idea is
the two opposite sides of the square
being active
so that neither one can see what the
other one's doing
right
and why doesn't it work
well it's time to
the problem is that the
when the states turn
off wait i mean when one side sort of
goes dormant and passes it on it can be
left in any number
it can there can be a number of
different states that's stopping in
and what after the after the if if
there's some kind of a mismatch here
that that that the glitch wasn't here
then after the baton moves over
to this point
i can see we think we've got some
garbage over here that we we're not sure
we can get the baton through again well
yes the one baton they leave behind
stuff with the other ones if you i think
if you stick in two more two-state
processes you might i'd use an odd
number
five number of the times ramsey
okay
but it will definitely work
so there was a problem of
getting around
garbage and how come that didn't
put in the car here is this uh
we're just lucky
we'll see
there's really only one way that i mean
when the baton goes through there's only
one way it can leave things
it just changes
well there's so there are four there are
sort of four ways in this case
i mean
um
let me see
i've got this preceded by gamma i that's
a little bit
um
that's a little bit flaky uh
if i if if i only knew that the that
uh that i never had to
to get this toothpick when looking at
its
as previous neighbor then i would say a
lot simpler because gamma has to have
lots of stakes at the at its right
uh but if
otherwise i could say that alpha i could
either go to alpha i plus one or some
alpha i plus one prime there would be
three or four possible things that it
could go to
and maybe maybe we could narrow down
the possibilities that way
um
uh but then again if it doesn't go to
the right one
then um
then i have to argue that there must be
a that must get to a good cycle somehow
from somewhere else yeah
well
one never knows in a research problem
whether or not there's going to be an
answer to it and that's another thing
about this and you know this uh
it's uh sometimes
happens in this class that nobody solves
a problem that
that was that was opposed we got to take
the
um you know we we got partial results
only sometimes
one of them went went for five more
years and then it was solved by
by one of the students uh
who had a bright idea you know years
later
but um
uh but uh we we shouldn't give up on it
until we know until we until we put to a
given a good shake right and uh and
there's also of course the ways that i
said that to find other
other similar problems going with uh
uh
saying let's just let's just take a
small in and do our best for for some
small dive event
all right now so we got we got only one
more minute to go is there is any
other
uh
thoughts that somebody might contribute
to
okay everybody's asleep or confused
you know confused is not the word we're
just uh we're just thinking uh yes only
go off into a
into a quiet room and uh and see if it's
uh
and see what the real
uh what the real solution is okay um
i wish mike
well he leaves this weekend for the for
the national
programming competition in
in louisiana we know that the stanford
team is going to wipe everybody else out
yes